[Music]
what is that magical sound eye here
yeah you know what song like the most
when you play i like uh
the la la land song yeah
it's pretty
all right so over here we got some
leftover action going on it's lunch time
and tiff went out to go run some errands
and she's gonna eat out
right here we got some lomo saltado and
some
it looks like boiled chicken and i guess
honey and chicken really is just boiled
chicken and i took the skin off and
everything so it looks really really
boring
but you throw this sauce on top of that
and that becomes really really amazing
the other day i was taught i don't know
who i was talking to i think i was
talking to tim and tim was saying
because he's in he's really really
involved in the food world
especially online stuff and uh he was
telling me how
a food critic got caught up in a twitter
firestorm because
she was basically saying hainan chickens
overrated and a lot of asian americans
and
just asians in general started roasting
her about how
she doesn't know what hainan chicken is
all about if she thinks hainan chicken
is boring and i have to i have to agree
with my asian peeps i think
that whole thought process is kind of
like a byproduct of what you want to
take pictures of the food because
certain foods just they
look colorful and they look delicious
they look like they're full of flavor
but sometimes there's those like
traditional dishes that
they sneak up on you they don't have a
whole lot of color they don't seem like
they're gonna have a whole lot of flavor
but honey and chicken is one of those
that it does
don't be sleeping on high nan chicken
bam
leftover day love leftover day because
it's a little bit of everything and
actually i've been
i've been cooking very internationally
i've been intermixing
peruvian food with chinese food with
korean food with japanese food
making everything and throwing it all
into one pile
kind of like i guess in this day and age
you don't really have buffets anymore
and we don't know if buffets will ever
come
back so i'm making buffets happen at
home but anyways before i forget this
video is sponsored by
drop drop is an easy to use rewards app
that allows you to earn points when you
make purchases at your favorite brand
they have over
300 retailers for example postmates
grubhub disney plus the list goes on and
because of the state of the world that
we're in right now we've been ordering a
lot of things online
we've been ordering food and the drop
app allows you to earn points every
single time you order
and here's how it works so we've been
thinking about getting a new
kitty litter for the cats and might as
well get some rewards already so what
you do is you open drop and we went to
the section where it says stacked deals
and this is where you get like the best
deals possible and we just so happen to
come across a deal
for pretty litter which is a brand of
kitty litter we've come across multiple
times and with five days left to go
we decided to purchase some pretty
litter for our cats once you're on the
pretty litter page you can scroll down
and discover more about the brand
then you hit get code and shop and it'll
take you right to pretty litter where
you can order with your code
and then you check out like you normally
would and drop will automatically add
your points
to your account so over time you're
gonna be earning lots and lots and lots
of points and it feels like you're
getting a discount with every purchase
you make and not only that your points
turn into free gift cards at places such
as starbucks
amazon sephora you can even double dip
and earn points on your credit card
and drop at the same time so download
drop with my link in the description
below and use code
tiffincase to receive a 10 000 point
bonus
which will be deposited when you first
earn your 1 000 worth of points by
completing offers on the app this offer
will only be available for one week so
sign up for the app and make sure to use
my code tiffin case for a chance to win
big hello everyone look what i have here
it's the beautiful leia leia show them
your reindeer
oh reindeer so pretty
she decided to wear her christmas outfit
and i decided to wear my thanksgiving
shirt
just kidding look here's christina and
enzo and isaac
this little boy just woke up from a nap
yep that's why he's so happy
you watch hold on good morning say hi
everybody
good morning hi hi
look at this prepared for some sushi yes
i just want sushi
i will bring all the goods i know
so tonight we're doing a dinner of all
our favorites
because every time we go out it's either
sushi or korean barbecue yeah that's
true
yeah that's true it's always
[Music]
he's going to do the sushi i'm taking
care of the korean bbq nice
why do you look so stressed man what's
going on i'm just really tired
oh man yard oh yeah you're staining it
yeah i was uh putting the wood stain all
day on it
and then also uh this guy didn't go to
sleep till 5
30 in the morning yesterday oh no night
and he kept crying while you put him
down oh no is it because you're
teething let me see those teeth let me
see those cute little
teeth how have you been you've been a
good big sister
it's the kitty cat it's the kitty cat
that's like the best
i love it when you guys come over it's
it's our favorite time of our bi-weekly
appointments because we decided to have
like a bi-weekly
hangout most of the time it's been them
coming over here so the kids can like
take a break from their environment and
come to a new environment i know the
last time we came over
we're having this discussion or like a
dispute because we're like
is it bi-weekly or is it semi-monthly oh
right
what is it yeah yeah i think
is it semi-monthly i thought it was five
months later oh buy monthly
five monthly i don't know i mean two two
or half two two two okay yeah
it means two we could all agree on that
five
yeah buy monthly or uh oh right because
bi-weekly
[Music]
listen i woke up from a nap too okay
every other week is what i tried
to say with by bi-weekly but that's
incorrect
we're twinning look we're all twinning
all three of us we're all holding babies
how cute look at this cat oh my gosh
look at you
stop being so cute okay he stopped he
stopped as soon as i said stop being
cute it's like 100
i know man leah's making me remember
what this
left mom arm looks like like the strong
left mom arm
carrying a kid on your on your waist
right here it doesn't hurt my back when
i'm holding her but when i'm holding him
right now i'm like oh i feel it oh yeah
she's bigger i know because boys are
like just heavier i think so
oh you want to play with the kitty
right over here oh you're trying to go
upstairs you want to say hi to maya
maya's upstairs
what's going on she has a sneaky
sneaky look he's trying to stack like
soft stuff
he's so slippery so cute
good job tada we made it oh wait no we
did it
oh here we go tada we made it
where's the other kitty cat let me see
is she back here
nope i don't know where she went you use
this for the cat's leia
i know right she's like i'm only i only
want to come for the cat
that's it kitty cat look at her yeah
on the bed maybe you want to go check
under isaac's bed
look at that smile dude look at this
smile
let's see kitty cat under isaac's bed is
she under here
look is she there it's too dark
no she's not under here but there's an
almond though that's so random
all right so one of the things i'm most
excited about hann's visit today
is the fact that he's gonna make sushi
i've always wanted to learn how to make
sushi i'd never took it upon myself to
figure out how to do it
i know there's a lot of stuff on youtube
that tells you how to make it and how to
cut it
how to marinate the right yeah hungry
hat video hungry and videos dude then
that's right check out hungry and videos
well i'm gonna give you a live show
today yes yes there's nothing better
than having a teacher in front of you
physically in front of you
he's also a good friend that's all you
know that's going to teach you how to
make sushi so this is
awesome cannot wait and aunt just told
me that he's going to get fancy with it
so he's going to
make some regular salmon sushi and he's
also going to do some ponzu
uh salmon sushi and some uh what do you
call it seriously
seared salmon sushi he's brought
blowtorch thingy majiggy and then we're
also gonna make some spaghettio sushi
[Laughter]
all right so what's the first thing you
just did right now um i'm putting
homemade smells gnarly by the way sushi
vinegar
sushi vinegar yeah so i got homemade
homemade
okay what's what's that mean homemade i
mixed a bunch of different ingredients
and boiled it and then once i pulled it
down
that's when i put it into the rice god
well it's got its own little specialty
like you can go to the store and just
buy a bottle of sushi vinegar the
restaurants don't do that
you know it's a little bit like sour and
like right it's a little more pungent
right yeah
i bet i bet this one's got a little more
sweetness with a vinaigrette
okay okay but i bought the ones from the
store before so i guess i lied i have
tried making it at home before but it's
nowhere close like the way the
store-bought stuff marinates the rice it
it's almost like no flavor
like it just tastes like regular writer
unless i just didn't put enough of it in
but i don't know regardless i
didn't come close to what i was
expecting i use it sometimes actually
when i'm lazy yeah is there a specific
way to
work the rice in like without smooshing
the rice or whatever
there is so usually i use a wooden um
container
so it kind of helps even out oh you're
like you're like an iron chef
because i've seen i've seen those
episodes against the wooden rice
container yeah
so what i'm doing now is kind of like
the fast way but usually
i'll dab it on here and i'll sprinkle it
like that and then
i'll use this end and i'll push the rice
so i'm not smashing i'm just pushing it
so the vinegar kind of evens out
okay so every single piece of grain gets
the vinegar
gotcha gotcha yeah this is gonna double
as a vlog
in my actual study notes
i'm gonna fall back on this video to
learn how to make sushi when there's
clumps we wanna get rid of those clumps
okay we're working on it we're we just
caught our fish
now we're gonna slay the fish and then
we're gonna serve it so i'm just patting
it dry a little bit
gotcha getting this fishy flavor out of
there
oh like that the layer of that that the
the mucus that builds on top
yeah yeah you don't wash it over the
sink though no i don't because it washes
the flavor away
yeah we're gonna start shaping it so we
can use it as uh
sushi pieces oh you have to shape it
yeah okay so with my
barbecue background i understand shaping
it so like with ribs and stuff
you do have to trim the rib up a little
bit after you've got it out the package
make each rib you know nice and tidy
are those pieces no good we'll use them
as for like the rolls when you stick it
in the middle
yeah well what you can do is if you
split it like this
yeah then now you can use it
these are some small pieces that i'm
cutting actually maybe it's the shape of
the fish
that looks better over here though it's
like thicker it's the real
the real size
[Music]
wait so did you cut against grain or
with crane or
what were you looking for so the way
they cut the fillets they cut it
for you so you know where to cut like
because this piece is smaller yeah i
already have to just start cutting from
here
because i'm really gonna lose a piece by
trying to shape it
yeah so i don't want to waste it on the
good side
i just go by the shape of it dude okay
yeah i guess
it's against the green that's why these
look pretty beautiful
[Music]
what time are you getting picked up
isaac um oh he's not he's
you're staying party with isaac
oh because we're going to the thing on
the side halloween oh that's right
i was going to tell you guys do you want
to get pumpkins
so aunt's got the wasabi out now he's
got he's up to no good death
jeff aunt's gonna put wasabi inside the
sushi it's your chance
this is your dream i did it i put it on
all of them already what are we gonna do
what are we gonna do just kidding we
haven't done anything i actually was
telling aunt that uh you don't like
wasabi and so to make some
without wasabi oh yes specific
specifically for you
it'd be really cool for you to finally
tell a sushi chef in person
to not have wasabi because these are the
best you have to relay it through the
waitress and all that stuff
well now when we're in the sushi bar oh
true you're right
you're right you're right holy crap you
just did that so fast like a taco guy
oh yeah like that yeah chocolate guys
work so fast you're making me nervous
why the camera's making you nervous
you've never made it
you made sushi in front of cameras
before you're on camera you might have
mom
went around do you have your seaweed
do you need it no we're just doing sushi
oh nikita
i'm just trying to make it easy if we
did the whole package i've been here for
hours you want to try it sure
yeah whoa he's open he his palate's
opening up
is it another one of those i'm only
going to eat it so you're proud of me
situation definitely that's what
happened last time
oh true true like there was a whole
scent with isaac not liking sushi at all
and then there was like a period of time
where he's like i like it now and
he'll actually eat salmon raw salmon and
then he'll just be eating it all the
time
but then later on we find out i only ate
it because i wanted to make you proud
and i was like oh i think you don't have
to do that true i did a lot of those too
when i was growing up i hated a bitter
melon and
it's literally called bitter melon and
it's bitter i'd eat it and drink it like
the bitter melon
soup and all that stuff and i pretend to
like it it's like i wanted to make my
parents proud and like
be like oh i'm a grown-up i like bitter
flavors too and
totally hated it
what's the secret to doing the the rice
having good form
form yeah the way you hold it and the
way you can tilt through it and push it
you got it oh i'll show you one right
here yeah i'm actually can i can i get
in
yeah get in on this we'll grab like
maybe like this without smashing it
we're just forming it
so i'm making it into a little ball
right now very little so we're going to
put it on your
left hand right in this pocket
okay we're going to squeeze it like this
without smashing the rice and do that
with your finger
and push down and squeeze at the same
time flip it upside down
and then now use your thumb right here
and
push squeeze use your finger on top so
now we're
molding it one more time look at this
look at this i'm a sushi chef that looks
fun
yeah you want to make some i should have
washed my hands and you guys see why you
need to have your hands
yeah that's why you got to go fast oh
that's good yep and then form into a
little ball
in your left hand in a ball but you
don't want to smash it smash it you want
to keep it kind of loose
and then uh put in your left hand and
then
you see when you do this there's like a
pocket between your fingers and your
palm of your hand that monkey right here
put it there and then you want to close
these four fingers down
put your thumb on this part of it and
then put your finger here
and then just slightly press in and kind
of mold it into that
rectangular shape and then after you do
that turn it over
[Music]
and then do the same thing do the other
side
and press into it and let it take shape
there you go so what i do is i'm doing
the top and then i'm going like this to
the sides
so it stays on the sides and when i flip
it i put my thumb here so the rice
doesn't come out
and then just like that so wasabi on the
fish
[Music]
fingers your finger is making the curve
on the top
okay and your thumb here is compressing
both sides
so it doesn't fall apart and then
this is fun this is better than making
dumplings so if you want to go over the
ultimate curve
yeah we do this right yeah and then
i go like pinch so now it's making
oh and it comes off oh i love it when it
goes over the top like that
[Music]
so the faster you do it the better
because
your hand is hot so the longer you have
in your hand you're going to make the
feet warmer
oh true the fish one all right so we
spent the last 10 minutes making sushi
this is our beautiful sushi platter all
salmon platter
hey isaac learned how to make it too yes
you did how do you like it
it's cool is it fun it's fun yeah we got
two cameras
two different vlogs going on at the same
time we have a better conversation over
here because we're cooler we're so cool
we have the we have the flame torch we
have the flame torch yeah
it's so cool what's going on
whoa that is really cool holy crap
oh snap isaac look
that that's badass now with the sauce my
homemade
spicy mayo sauce
sushi chef right here sushi chef
material
now with the ponzu sauce
this is a special ponzu sauce yep i made
this too some ingredients i have
um on my hungry aunt that you guys can
make but things like the ponzi sauce and
spicy milk i don't think i did that
there's a secret i have a few secrets
that i never release either
yeah cooking videos do you guys like
using pepper i'll
i'm i'm open oh i love that oh very open
perfect it's like japanese tajin for me
so the back of the spoon is very
important if you don't have a back of a
spoon
definitely got to get it back of the
stone for sushi making only the bag
yeah forget the spoon part just the back
of the spoon do you
want to try a truffle oil one oh yes
i've never been a truffle
fan oh okay up until i had it fresh but
i realized the flavor i don't like comes
from truffle oil
yeah fresh truffles pretty nice putting
a little bit of salt on it
this is just for the uh truffle oil one
got it dang you have you're like a
chemist here you know that stuff's
expensive when it's an
eye drop thing we got the seared salmon
with spicy mayo
and then we have the ponzu salmon with
yuzu and then we have the truffle oil
salmon and here's the regular ones
these all have no wasabi oh this is all
for you
the salmon platter's for you
brought to you by hungry aunt
casey casey uh
cook chef boyar isaac
yeah your son made you sushi you did
hungry isaac
hungry isaac hungry or isaac they're
just biting ants
branding yeah totally all right
so out of all the ones i made what do
you think you want on the wasabi
dish uh two seared
or truffle oils
yeah two and a half i got a blend you're
an artist an artiste
an cheese oh got a little excited
next we just have to get the salmon
straight out of the ocean
and then have aunt do it yes
do a fishing trip guys do you know how
to take apart a fish
yes i've done it before oh snaps but
you're for real
it's been like 15 years oh wow you want
all the truffle
oh truffle lover over here which one do
you recommend uh trying first
i like the ponzu for
this is you're talking to a real chef i
meant the other ones
don't insult the chef
all right here's the taste test
you're welcome cheers
[Music]
i just remembered i'm missing lemon
hmmm
that's just number one can you guys just
come over every day
we can move in yeah all right
wait are we eating this whole plate what
about you guys we'll eat after it's okay
that's all you right there okay
now there's lemon on it let us know if
it makes a difference
a little bit that was here
which one is isaac going to try the
regular one
look at that
or anything it's like overly smooth yeah
these are cooked all the way through but
this is just like right on the top
yeah that's what the true meaning of a
sear is it's just the top layer
they just put cooked salmon on it i hate
that yeah oh the truffle
christina's favorite right there there
we go here we go
[Music]
yeah good bomb right i feel like a
winner
i don't know i feel like a champion all
of a sudden i'm just eating delicious
food this is amazing
anytime you want to buy some fish have
me over and i'll make it for you guys
but you can make it now too these are
these are your pieces over here that you
made
how about the cutting those did you
learn the cutting yes i didn't do it
today but
i saw how it's done honestly i think the
ponzo was my favorite
yeah it's so good
that's awesome thank you aunt you're
welcome so now i'm gonna learn how to
cut
fish and then once i mastered this i am
a sushi chef
and ant's gonna give me a certificate
today
yeah right you think it just takes one
night to become a soup
i don't know what you learned from me oh
yeah that's how good of a teacher
yeah from this point on once you master
it i'm no longer gonna make it i'm just
gonna eat what you make
damn what am i doing about my pressure
is on teach a man a fish
this is how you want it angled every
time and you're going to use almost the
whole knife in one slice
so you'll start from the back and do
that once the fish has been cut
you're going to turn the knife and cut
the rest off okay how do i do sensei
not too bad it's a great it's a great
shape um
and actually you didn't waste any at all
all right so now we're gonna make them
thicker
keep going okay stop now turn it a
little bit and cut down
down this way yep there you go so
i told you a little too soon in my bag
oh okay okay yeah so you saw you're bad
i'm so good
hey he's been a humble student make it
bigger
and then down yep all in one motion no
stop okay
does that create that's a pretty good
one yeah what is that what does this uh
theme do right here this little ridge um
it's just so you don't get like a thin
piece
so like oh there's there's a bite to it
yeah oh that's the trick
oh that's good oh okay okay that's good
[Music]
oh yeah that's a good piece yeah but
then so this is great
we just want to get a little bit thicker
because once you put on the rice it
might start to tear
i see why you need to go fast too yeah
or else we're going to eat like next
year
when it gets sticky you can rinse off
the knife so now you're going to cut
here and before it gets to the edge
you're kind of
you're butterflying the sunlight right
now there you go
which side is the top this side yeah but
in a sushi restaurant they would
actually just make it into a roll or
something like that
a good start oh you angled a lot okay
yeah
how cute a flying baby
i got bored with the sushi making i had
to go look at the kids
sorry he fell asleep yeah i fell asleep
actually you got through it pretty fast
you're okay you got attacked
i know leia leia princess leia
that's it man it's uh nice
start putting it together okay i don't
need to use too much water because i
have sweaty hands
gross that's why it tastes good right
[Applause]
now i think about that i'm like i'm
eating like
the dna of it each sushi chef that i
that makes my sushi because i'm like
making a thousand pieces during a rush
i'm like this
right gross the same reason why i don't
want to know how my food is made like
when they slaughter animals and stuff
i'm like i don't want anything about
this
i don't know i want to be ignorant you
know there's other sushi chefs that like
when they're talking to you at the bar
and they're making their food and like
here you go and then there's pickles
or like at the din some places you know
how they wear those like face masks
yeah yeah well i might as well get some
b-roll
i know you guys are vlogging and then
we're vlogging and then you can check
out their blog on their channel
and then you can check out our vlog on
our channel because you are
you can check
what you guys both need to do is just
get two monitors
i have them both playing at the same
time oh
i don't get it i don't know i don't get
it either all i want to say is um
just keep making the food yeah yeah
we're hungry
[Laughter]
all right we are now outdoors in the
backyard and what do we got going on
here isaac
i am cooking our brick brisket korean
barbie for style
[Music]
and the baby's all set up that's right
he's ready to go to sleep i know
honestly i'm kind of ready to go to
sleep so that sushi fills me up
like surprisingly i didn't think sushi
would fill me up like that maybe it's
all the little extra ingredients that we
had
pretty much had a whole plate to
yourself yeah i did i did
me too actually yeah you wanted some too
hello
who's who's playing the piano oh you
wanna take me
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go see your let's
go see your blood brother play the piano
let's go see enzo play the piano
where are we going
[Music]
is uh playing the piano now he's
entertaining the entire
room good job you're doing great keep
going there we go
very well pure natural talent right here
the next mozart
yep you're over it okay yeah you need a
break
i was telling your husband outside i'm
like dude we can babysit whenever you
want
are you sure about that we'll handle it
we got
three people here who can handle kids
how about one week
well i said one night pushing it a
little bit
he was like i still need my boobie he's
gonna go after yours
oh wait till i have milk and then we'll
see
no he'll be like ew you're not my mama
he's gonna be like three years old
no i mean that's if i'm pregnant but i'm
not so yeah you're probably right he's
gonna be like three years old by the
time
i have any milk i'm sorry dude i won't
be able to help you
[Music]
you